today i'm going to demonstrate a simple
way to install backflow prevention
between the faucet and a fertigation
feeder
the backflow preventer or tank valve is
a critical piece of the irrigation
system
the backflow preventer is true to its
name
it prevents irrigation water from
re-entering or back flowing into the
water supply
backflow sometimes called back siphoning
occurs when there is a negative pressure
or pressure loss on the supply side of
the irrigation system
without a functioning backflow
prevention there is a risk of
contaminating the water supply
it is important to make sure that you
install the backflow preventer in the
correct direction when installing it
make sure to look for the manufacturer's
stamped directional arrow that is
located on the side of the backflip
event
the backflow preventer can be installed
using a glue fitting as shown or as a
threaded fitting depending on the model
that is used
the arrow is the direction of water
flowing through the pipe if the backflow
preventer is installed backwards then it
will stop the flow of water to your
field
we hope this video was very useful
please check out our video series to
learn all the steps in installing a
simple irrigation system on a small
phone thank you
you